On TikTok there is a dog named Noodle. Now
each day Noodle either wakes up with bones
as seen here, where he has enough strength
to stand, or with no bones where he flops
back down onto the bed. Noodle has become kind
of a guiding force for the daily mood of the
internet. On a bones day people are encouraged
to get out of bed and make the most of their day,
maybe take a risk or try something new, whereas
a no bones day might be the time to take it easy
and think a little bit about self-care. So what
does this have to do with quantum computing?
Well almost nothing but I did notice that the
chance of a bones to a no bone day does seem
to be about 50 50. That's the same chance that a
qubit in an even superposition of states 0 and 1
would have of being measured in either
state. I recently found out that quantum
computing is actually further ahead than
where I thought it was and in fact right
now anyone can submit code to be run on a real
quantum computer so to figure out how to do that
I set out to ask a real quantum computer 'Bones
or no bones?' The answer might come from some
point of deep intrinsic truth about our universe
or maybe it's just pretty close to truly random.
This video is sponsored by Qiskit which is
IBM's open source quantum computing software.
With Qiskit we can use the python coding language
to actually program circuits and algorithms for
a quantum computer. IBM also give access to the
hardware having already built quite a few quantum
computers. These are currently only relatively
small and used for experimental purposes.
IBM recently unveiled their largest one
to have 127 qubits but we're still away
off from these quantum systems being large
enough to outperform the classical computers.
IBM have made their smaller five qubit quantum
computers free for anyone to use you just have
to submit your code through the IBM quantum lab
but before I could run my little experiment I
first had to learn just enough about qubits,
quantum circuits and programming with Qiskit
to actually write my program and I'll
quickly fill you in on what I've learned.
All right so it's important to
know what we're dealing with here.
In classical computing information is stored
using bits and these can either be zero
or one, they're binary and
they're like tiny little switches.
Now bits all act independently of each other
and we can manipulate bits using logic gates.
There are quite a few different
kinds of logic gates but for example
one of them is the NOT gate. The NOT gate
can be drawn like this and it would turn a
zero into a one or a one into a zero. Now when
we're dealing with quantum computing we're dealing
with something called the qubit and these are just
quantum bits. We can represent qubits as an arrow
pointing on the surface of a sphere.
Let's see if I can draw a sphere in here.
I'll actually draw a couple.
All right so if we have say an arrow pointing
on our sphere and if that arrow is pointing
straight up well that qubit would be in the zero
state and if the arrow was pointing straight down
then that qubit would be in the one state. But the
arrow can also point anywhere else on the sphere.
Our arrow could point to the side like this and
this qubit is in a superposition of the zero and
one states. Now when you measure a qubit you do
still only get out a zero or a one as the result
and that's because measurement collapses the
superposition. If you were to keep measuring the
same qubit again and again you would get the same
result. It is only before measurement takes place
that a qubit is able to exist in multiple states
at once which gives it the ability to do things
that classical bits can't. That means if you've
got a program that's working with qubits you'll
try to keep measurement to the last step in the
process. If we were to measure this superposition
here we would find that because the arrow is
pointing halfway between the zero and one that
there would be a fifty percent chance of returning
a zero upon measurement and a fifty percent chance
of getting a one. If instead the arrow had been
pointing maybe more towards the zero that might
have given an eighty percent chance of a zero,
twenty percent chance of one. And likewise down
here this arrow might have given eighty percent
chance for one, twenty percent chance of a zero.
But physically how do you make a qubit? Well
there are actually several types. It's just any
two-state quantum system such as the spin of an
electron or the polarization of a single photon.
IBM uses superconducting transmon cubits
which are a superconducting material
on a silicon chip arranged so that there is an
artificial atom with quantized energy levels
and then kept extremely cold
in a ground state of zero.
Radiation can be applied to excite the qubit
to the one state or to enter a superposition.
I spent some time on the Qiskit online textbook
learning the absolute basics and I'm pretty happy
that I've managed to get some working code. I've
just written it on the IBM quantum lab server
so you don't even need to download anything if
you don't want to. My code starts with importing
everything we need and then I also got it to print
a list of the available hardware that I can run
the code on. It lists the five qubit quantum
computers I can use as well as some simulators
which make more sense when you're just testing
the code. This little code here is setting up
my circuit it's actually fairly simple and
there's a diagram here of what's going on.
q is my one qubit and all qubits start initialized
at 0 which is their ground state but I want it
to be in a 50/50 superposition so i've applied a
quantum logic gate that is the H symbol here. It
is the Hadamard gate. Now when it comes to quantum
logic gates there are some that are similar to
their classical counterparts. For example there
is a quantum NOT gate and it's represented as an
X like the classical NOT gate that we looked
at. This one has the ability to turn a zero
into a one or a one into a zero. It essentially
flips the sign and we can even see how this is
represented physically with our sphere. If inside
our sphere we set up some axes so maybe a y there,
an x, and up and down to be z, then you can
actually see where the quantum NOT gate gets its
symbol the X from. It actually flips the arrow
over the x axis. So if we had a qubit that was
say a zero, meaning that the arrow was pointing
straight up, then if it was to be flipped across
the x-axis it would come out looking like a one.
Likewise there are some quantum logic gates called
y and z that flip it over those axes too. But
the H gate that we want to use in our circuit
is kind of unique to the quantum world. After
passing through an H gate, a qubit that started as
zero will have a fifty percent chance of being
zero and a fifty percent chance of being one.
But the H gate isn't just a randomizer, for
example if you were to pass a qubit through
two H gates one after the other it would basically
undo the effect and you would get back whatever
value you started with and that's not behavior
you would expect from something that's just
randomizing the results. Something else is going
on here. What the H gate is actually doing is
applying a rotation around the line between
the x and the z axes so this line in here.
Now you might be able to see that if an arrow
had been pointing straight up representing zero
then flipping it over this line would put it here
halfway between zero and one meaning it has fifty
percent chance of being measured as zero and
fifty percent chance of being measured as one.
Then if you were here and you did another
rotation back around the same axis
so you've applied your second H gate well you
would actually end up back where you started,
back at zero and so you can see
why two H gates do undo the effect.
The last component in my circuit is a
measurement to collapse the superposition.
I'm first going to run the code on the simulator.
I've set shots equal to 1 which means we're
going to run this one time and we'll get one
result out of our qubit. It'll either be a 0
and in that case it'll be a no bones
day or we'll get a 1 which will be
a bones day. So running this now it prints out
that the result 1 was obtained one time and that
makes it a bones day. Running it again we see
that 0 was now returned as the result. But let's
increase the number of shots so that we have more
than one result. I can increase it to a hundred.
This time it says that the result 1 was returned
45 times and 0 was returned 55 times so we're
getting close to a 50/50 split but we're not quite
there yet. And just to see what happens let's go
for a hundred thousand shots, all right getting
even closer to 50/50 here. I think we can be
pretty confident that this code is getting us into
that superposition that we want. Now I think we're
ready to run it on the real quantum computer.
We can come on to the Quantum Lab dashboard
and see all of the quantum computers and whether
they're online and what their queues look like.
We will need to join the end of the queue for
whatever job we want to run so hopefully we can
find something where the queue is pretty short.
These are actually their large machines, the 127
cubit one up there in Washington, but we're going
to want to use the smaller five qubit machines.
In fact what we're doing only needs one qubit
really. Looking here the machine in Bagota has
the smallest queue with only seven pending
jobs so what we'll do is we'll copy that
name take it to our code and tell it
that that's the back end we wish to use.
Let's just do it with one shot because we want
to find out what kind of day we're going to have
and if we run this it will send
it off to the quantum computer.
I can check up on it in this tab here which are
all the jobs that i've sent. It says an estimated
time of two minutes till completion but for
you after the edit that might be a lot shorter.
And we've got our result, it's a bones day!
It took 2 minutes and 21 seconds to get the
result. You can see here it says that a 1
was measured with 100% probability and my
code returned that it is a bones day. That's
wonderful news for all. Do something amazing,
go learn quantum computing, maybe work on that
side project or write some new year's resolutions.
Just so you know, whenever this video
reaches you is when your bones day applies
so even if you're watching this in the future it
applies to you too. We can send another request
off with more shots maybe try 10 000 this time
just to check our distributions. When running
things on these real quantum computers, noise is
also something that you usually have to take into
account. I think for us since this is so simple
and just with one qubit it doesn't really apply
but more complicated programs would really have
to consider noise in their results. Our result is
in in six minutes 39 seconds to say that 0 was
returned 53% of the time, 1, 46% of the time.
Mine is a pretty trivial use but there are
lots more of those more complicated algorithms
on Qiskit that you can use and that actually take
advantage of the quantum abilities. For me this
is just a really cool way to learn but it can
also be practical if you're actually wanting a
career somewhere in quantum computing. Here is
a current active job listing from IBM quantum,
it's for a Qiskit researcher. You can see some of
the responsibilities here. It may be no surprise
to see that in required experience they want
you to have done some research projects already
using Qiskit. They also want you to have
working knowledge of quantum computing
and at least a master's degree. If working on
quantum computers in this kind of way is something
you think you'd like to do then learning something
like Qiskit is really going to help you get there.
Make the most of your bones day maybe
commit to learning a skill like this
or applying for a new job. Thanks for
watching this video and thanks to my
Patreon supporters. A special thanks to today's
Patreon cats of the day Stinky and Sprinkles.